My name is Tim Lincecum and I'm a world championship baseball player.
I got started with baseball just 'cause I came from a family of baseball players.
I think that's what kinda got me into it.
Coming up, my biggest motivator was fear.
You know, the fear of maybe not living up to expectations or,...
...maybe fear of not being able to play with, you know, guys that are bigger than you.
You know, mentally, I think it's one of those things where you're almost dumbfounded out there...
...you're just kinda going out there with a purpose obviously,...
...I wanna throw strikes and good strikes at that.
When I'm pitching and it's going really well, there is no pain.
Going on obviously there's strenuous points in there.
I think the biggest one for me is when I take my long stride towards home plate...
...and, you know, my lower body is on the target while my upper body isn't...
...the last thing I need to think about is rhythm.
Whether it's the song that I'm coming out to or it's counting in my head.
I try to have that help me with my rhythm.
And if you do things right, the road will take you to the World Series.
I'm Tim Lincecum, a world championship pitcher...
And baseball is for me one of the biggest loves of my life.